we sat down with him and asked what
motivates his charity work everybody
knows us I came from nothing you know I
even sleeping in the street with with
cartoon and and also sometimes we were
hungry starving we don't have our own
house so this you know people are knows
that I'm successful in life so I go back
to where I came from and then what
learning build a house build a community
a village and build a house and give it
to the family who don't have a house
right now we already give giving almost
800 houses 400 houses for the families
who don't have a house you were injured
when you fought your last fight as it
turns out you had an injury I think
during training now how are you doing
with the injury and what's your what are
your plans to return to the ring
no injuries the operation is successful
and I'm getting 992 80 to 90% well and
my injury and I believe that I can they
can fight the next year early and mature
early next year with Mayweather a
rematch I don't know I didn't know but
good thing if he's willing to do it are
you willing to do it of course of course
yes yes yes so that we have no - Floyd
Mayweather no deployment you said you
don't wanna fight anymore
guess what Manny does is one of the many
people were somewhat disappointed with
the fight it was the hottest ticket the
most success I know I know I know and
people said I want more what was your
takeaway did you feel like you should
deliver more a bigger fight a lot I mean
I did my best in the ring everybody
knows that and what again what I'm gonna
do is keep on moving keep on moving you
don't want to fight through the toe and
just you want just to finish that well
bronze you see the best fighter you have
a faced Mayweather we see the best
fighter know there's a lot of big
fighter that I fought before like De La
Hoya
Marquez Marquez Miguel Cotto was Ricky
Hatton yeah and of course Margarito do
you want to run for president that's not
in my mind right now my main focus is to
run as a senator which is higher than
that as a congressman so the step by
step but I don't have that in my mind
right now it's so important to you it
seems to do the right thing do you think
you can take part in cleaning boxing up
it's not good for for sports of boxing
in into all the sports it's not good
image for everybody so that I think I
believe that this should be should pass
a law or punishment that everybody's
will aware and scared to to use an
enhancement drugs